as he does okay will we see a Queen's
Gambit will we see a nimso Indian
defense
plenty of options here for black
I suspect nimso Indian whether dark
Square Bishop will develop over to the
B4 square and pin the Knight it seems to
be so trendy at the minute yeah pregnant
has very good results there though
recently so maybe Hans just pausing for
thought
I think Han should go C5 that's more his
kind of you know Whiting chess yeah his
unbalanced position but he's gone for
the most traditional move there yeah so
now we have uh the ultimate Queen's
Gambit uh the Queen's Gambit declined
very trendy variation
strategic we're gonna see the Queens
come off black has a shattered Pawn
structure but black does have the bishop
pair and you saw hands there just kind
of lean back and slightly frown now yeah
I've seen this face before this is Hans
just trying to remember I don't know why
anyone plays this variation I mean
yeah I mean I'm just wondering if you
played it now David but no I've been
recommended to play it many times it has
a very good reputation for black but uh
at the top level at least but yeah it's
not much fun yeah I mean I think Hammer
showed some was it hammer or Magnus yeah
everything is Hammer's idea showed some
very clever maneuver but it just looks
horrible in structure and potentially
Black's bishop and yeah I know if you of
the two Bishops maybe maybe it's the
right thing to do but I could never
dream of playing this way with the black
piece it's just probably being a little
bit worse but yeah it is unbalanced so
yeah I mean you get some chances on the
queen side sometimes certainly
unbalanced and uh it's just about whose
style it favors more is it going to be
Prague style we've seen him play really
well in the end game so let's be honest
uh Neiman a bit more up and down
normally I mean we would think he favors
the chaos he wants Queens on the board
he wants some imbalances he did win an
end game against Prague in the last
round
um just before this so
um something to be said there Hans now
continuing very quickly but maybe we can
jump in just to highlight this uh why
we're both
um kind of conflicted about whether this
is a good choice for Neiman and it's
simply this Pawn structure these double
pawns they'll never be undoubled they'll
never be able to push forward
effectively this is also an isolated
pawn and a big Target sometimes in the
end game White's Bishop will Target this
Pawn Black's Bishop is often tied down
to the square for the rest to the game
just having to defend it if you could
imagine one of the white Knights as well
coming to the square the bishop coming
in this guy is uh the big key at the end
but okay first of all some maneuvering
preg is just kind of getting his pieces
ready maybe hinting at pushing a pawn in
the center at least asking the question
to hands are you ready for this is your
king feeling comfortable opposite my
Rook
um I like what prague's doing another
idea for white is to put the bishop on
the Square and then kind of at least try
to force the trade on White's terms but
uh maybe that Knight can come in as well
David on the edge I mean there's I I I
don't like this opening Choice from
hands I think it's playing right into
prague's style of play I think Prague
will you know he's very well prepared he
likes his kind of I like I mean he's
very good in all positions obviously all
the players are but this this to me is a
bad opening choice for black yeah it's a
style thing and yeah I I'm not sure it
plays to Neiman's strengths I still
think black is rock solid uh even if you
sit and do nothing for example if you
just bring your Rook to this Square
normally you can put your Rook on the
other Square you kind of maneuver around
with your knight you want to end up kind
of putting your knight on the Square
where this bishop sits quite often so
you might have to maneuver it around and
yeah as long as you can sit on a square
with this Black Knight that threatens to
maybe later jump into the center then
you're doing pretty well but yeah it's
this one it's going to be a grind we're
going to be sitting here for the next 20
30 minutes discussing plans small ideas
I'm probably just a bit biased because I
you know I'm just looking at a position
right now I don't like them you're
looking at these porn Simon yeah just
like you know the square in front those
pawns is often often something that
white can take over as well I mean um
it's it's you have to kind of just be
very patient to play these positions and
his hands are really patient player I
mean of course he's a great player he
can play patiently but he's going to
have to show that in this game yeah he's
capable but maybe it's not his number
one strength and also to I mean to
really emphasize the point of these
pawns if you ever push forward with this
Pawn as black
um for example uh in this position
instead of removing the Rook if Hans is
contemplating pushing forward with this
Pawn to clamp down on white ever
advancing here in the center or clamp
down and white advancing on this Square
then well he has just played it
um I'm not sure about this one but look
at this bishop now so ugly yeah I mean
this is a move you
normally only playing this variation if
you have to right it's Last Resort type
of move normally you want white to for
example have committed a pawn forward
first
um I was actually pointing out this move
as an instructive mistake something that
is well known not to do
um but Hans has played it and not after
that much thought either I mean I guess
who wants to get the Knight around to
the center but it's understandable
wanting the Knight to come around but
now what white can do you can just park
your knight on this Square forever and
even if the back Knight comes around
yeah you pack the busy tonight but now
white can just push forward with this
Pawn uh kind of stopping the white uh
the black knight from ever jumping
forward and look at this piece uh it's
still going to be hard to break through
with white you still need to kind of
initiate play on the other side of the
board maybe long term but this bishop
it's a dead piece it's Pawn it's a pawn
it's a pawn it's not even a bishop you
might as well uh just call it a pawn
you've made you've made it a pawn by
pushing the other one I mean oh that's a
very strange decision there from from uh
probably just panic because as David
alluded you know the Rook is opposite
the king and so he was so desperate to
stop that pawn break but I don't like
this decision at all I agree with you
both
yeah I'm not good it's just I mean
sometimes we talk about ugly pieces but
we think that they're ugly visually for
a reason and here it's just long term
strategically I mean black is
suffering and uh even if you ever take
this white knight it looks like you
double the white pawns but I'm not even
sure which way white captures but uh
yeah still it doesn't change the fact
that this bishop is just a pawn and it's
stuck here it can never even if you kind
of re-route it even if you're trying
sorry try and get it back it does have a
root out but it's just stuck here
defending this uh sorry porn it just
looks like a long-term mistake this last
Pawn Push by hands I've got to say and
okay he does Go For Trying to activate
the Black Knight into the square I'm
expecting now uh Prague to push his Pawn
he doesn't maybe need to do this but at
some point he will
I agree now Simon after this last Pawn
Push by black I agree all because of
this one bad piece
yeah I mean it's just no fun playing
this position either that's the other
thing I mean uh yeah you you've got to
suffer for quite a long time now
um very strange move that very strange
move it's not clear what Black's plan is
other than sitting and waiting maybe
black could expand on this side of the
board and this is where he has a four
versus three advantage on the left half
I guess with pawns but what do you do
after that you just have to sit and
suffer
yeah and why saddle yourself with a with
a bad bishop and it's dire and uh the we
see the bishop Retreats itself
because why not and whilst the players
are thinking I wanted to share with you
a selfie and also some tattoo
recommendations about David and
potentially Simon so Doge TK says more
chess Inc for David Howell I have a
nearly complete chess sleeve on my right
forearm and you can see it's actually
the match between Bobby Fisher and Boris
basket and there you can see Bobby
Fischer with his that concentration
waves I love that selfie yeah and uh
Liam Watson is saying my tat in
landscape
and I'm not sure I believe it's a tattoo
is that you just Leon using a marker
maybe
and meanwhile the porn moves is for some
forward taking space and I also wanted
to show you one more this is from ferret
who says David I think this is the
tattoo you need and I think you could
put it off for sure uh Simon higher
yeah it's a bravery I have to say you
know credit's forgetting that the
massive tattoo looks slightly painful oh
my gosh I'm sure my family would approve
maybe you two want to enter our selfie
competition then remember to tweet your
selfie in landscape mode using the
hashtag chest champs for a chance to win
the air things view Plus very cool and
we have some moves uh anything dramatic
happening so far not really black did go
for that plan of gaining space on the
queen side
but it's uh it's one that I think
pregnant would just ignore for now white
will just get his pieces ready I'm
slightly surprised he allowed the black
pawn the a pawn to continue pushing but
um not too big a deal there it's all
about whether Prague can break through I
think that's the question long term now
where is the Breakthrough we're going to
be asking ourselves that on every move
all right so if you were to get a tattoo
of a chess game or a chess match like we
saw Fisher against basket then what
would be one of these 200 Move games
today all the way down his back down his
leg down the other leg would be like a
score sheet I'll just get it printed out
online that would be kind of cool I
would actually be quite cool yeah so or
maybe yeah there are some moves uh
throughout my career that I'm especially
proud of my winning move against uh Ivan
sokolov who was actually the coach of
the winning Uzbek Uzbekistan team at the
Olympia recently one of my moves in that
game Queen h8 check that was do you
reckon you could ever move of all time
you mean could you get a load of theory
tattooed on your arm you know like you
know loads of variations of stuff all
your accessible courses Simon that would
also take a lot of I might need a bit
more skin for that myself yeah but I
could be like hang in a minute let's get
my tattoo out all right yes
yeah it's like Prison Break remember the
guy had the all the tattoos didn't he on
Prison Breakers she kind of escapes
there yeah we'll have to check that
yeah with the main Arbiter in Miami
Tanya would it be cheating to have a
chest tattoo with uh some analysis what
about a slogan are you allowed are you
allowed that like have you had some
chess thing like the chess speak for us
yeah something motivational or some kind
of that's not cheating no but I mean if
you had like remember not to move the
queen twice in an opening I don't know
something or something
totally but you know it's something that
you always do wrong just saying you've
got a tattoo yeah or you know go for the
win uh that oh that's allowed like
that's allowed oh we are frowning David
are you not liking this move
it's just so ugly for black look at that
black light Square Bishop in the corner
look at all the holes in Blacks half of
the board he's pushing forward gaining
space but in an end game I mean with
Queens off the board that's not really
relevant maybe Prague can bring his
other Knight around to G5 or something
you know like uh it just
yeah I think I think as you said though
David is like cat can white break this
down
um and I think black's trying to shore
up the queen side right to try to stop
things over there you mean you might
need to do a pawn break at some point
from White now if you have to play a
pawn break then where where is your Pawn
break but it's going to be a long game
trying to achieve that white has this
little Queen Side Pawn break B3 but I
kind of like you might as well move your
pieces as as many times as you can first
right like you said told us yesterday
David when you're looking at sending if
you've got a good position your
opponent's clearly just defending get
your pieces to the best guys first yeah
I mean
you know I was just I was inspired by
both you and Simon's words and you know
I was just thinking hang on a second
move the piece move the Knight on C3
they go on on Odyssey around the board
yeah oh look at that G5 it was the
squared of attention look look pretty
good there actually I mean there might
be other squares as well but jg5 is
definitely one one way you could
de-freeze the normal square foot as well
wasn't it nice position exactly another
idea that popped into my mind I'm not
sure what black does here say black just
Waits um your right Simon just move this
bishop kind of drop this Knight back
you've kind of got squares to jump into
later dark squares that are only barely
covered by Black's bishop and for
example if black continues to wait you
can jump back and jump into this square
and sooner or later you can start
stacking up your Rooks on the semi-open
file maybe you don't need Pawn breaks
maybe that's the key and uh if black
keeps waiting again
um just I mean it feels like maximum
pressure sooner or later you'll jump in
with a knight to the square or the
square and Black's position might well
just collapse I'm not sure that this is
the best Square for White's Bishop maybe
you could kind of transport it all the
way over to this side of the board to
Target this uh this weakness but yeah
you do have that time you have that
luxury most likely the game will
continue at a slow pace and it's just
about putting pieces on good squares for
Prague and the reason you can do this is
because black just can't do anything I
mean look at Black's Bishop it's
disgusting you know and it's like black
is a piece down black doesn't really
have anywhere to play I mean you can try
if you try something on the queen side
with Pawn push you can always be locked
down
um by by one of White's pawns and uh he
has got he's gone your way actually so
um which is a sensible idea as well and
I mean you try to win this position by
not moving your Pawns of white because
you know by moving pawns you create
different kind of different kind of
scenario and you might not need to do
that as again you mentioned there David
say yeah I mean another move that I
would love to have played at some point
over the next few over the last few
turns actually for white was to push
this Pawn forward but as you mentioned
just there Simon maybe your idea is to
push B3 at some point to open up some
lines on this side of the board and now
you no longer have that have that option
this Pawn is on a dark square and it
will be a target for the bishop later on
so yeah just why commit you don't need
to commit uh Prague will enjoy this
position for the next 20 30 40 moves and
just by dropping the bishop back he's
saying okay I've got all the Time in the
World to dance around with my Knights
this night's jumping back this night's
jumping back I'm gonna stack up my Rooks
eventually and uh it's also the theory
of two weaknesses blackheads and
weaknesses on this side of the board and
black also has this backward Pawn
um so yeah long term it just feels like
um black is going to be the one
suffering okay he puts his Rook now
hands on a semi-open file but this Pawn
is well protected by White's King I
don't really see what that does white
tonight will just drop back now over
protect this pawn and it will free up
the other night to start jumping
yeah still looks like one-way traffic to
me we're only 22 moves into the game is
this just a plan that went all wrong for
Hans or did he have the wrong plan yeah
and I think maybe Simon was right it was
just an opening that didn't suit him but
uh I think the key that's kind of turned
it in White's favor was putting a Pawn
on this Square just locking in his own
Bishop on a bad diagonal
um yeah one bad piece makes the whole
position bad
so yeah it just feels like the wrong
strategy and that often that happens in
chess right we just get a bad opening we
kind of commit to a plan it's the wrong
plan and we kind of we're consistent
with it but
um here it just doesn't look great
yeah this is so ugly for black now yeah
you even do it really is ugly isn't it
and well you just have to sit here yeah
I think you you can't really do anything
I mean you can maybe I suppose you could
show David if black tries to the only
porn idea he's got is this B4 but I mean
if he pushes Evo's Pawn's worst case
scenario white can just lock it in right
and those pawns might just be a bit
weaker by pushing them they're not doing
anything
um it's one of those ones I call it like
Lego uh you know you like Lego connects
together you know and if you push one
Pawn the other Pawn goes and you make
this sort of very blocked formation uh
light light Lego yeah
um and then you can just go back to
maneuvering your pieces to the best
squares and the thing is white has
squares he can move his pieces too but
black doesn't right black doesn't have
any good squares anywhere you can
improve his pieces White's got many ways
you can you can do that yeah there's
bits but I mean is it enough to win and
practice gotta I mean I'd imagine super
pranks got to prove it right
um if it was Magnus with the white
pieces I think we would just uh write
this one off as a win for white who's
texting you Simon I think it's a text my
phone does this thing not very
professional it should be turned off
thank you
um but it yeah it's Siri it's given me
ideas and whenever David says Magnus
it's like oh okay hello
[Music]
um
Magnus is here I've just named my phone
Magnus basically so uh if you were
playing Simon in Miami you'd be
disqualified now with that phone beeping
I would be yeah yeah maybe I should be
kicked off the commentary I'll turn it
off I'll turn it there's no Arbiters in
this room don't worry okay good good
yeah okay yeah no I I agree with you
both and one thing that kind of did
strike me is you know I think it was the
words from yesterday when I was asking
David what to do when you have a bad
position he's like just embrace the
suffering you just accept that you have
a bad position and you know just uh play
ugly chess
if needs must
and uh thinking you know maybe black
should just do that you know should just
try to control the squares that he's
given the dark squares and
again just react to whatever white
throws at him yeah it's just
psychologically hard I guess
um firstly especially for someone like
Hans Who Wants to Be Active he wants to
be entertaining all the fans to be
sitting there just kind of going up and
down and up and down with your Rook just
waiting for your opponent to break
through it's uh it's not a lot of fun
and also it is time consuming when you
have no plan and your opponent has a
clear-cut plan that they can follow step
by step that's why we see pregnant and
up on nearly 12 minutes and Hans ticking
down seven minutes and and Counting
um it's just yeah it's just hard to
adapt and we actually I'll see a little
bit of a similar pattern from
yesterday's match against Magnus where
Hans played a great game and then he
kind of was positionally crushed
and then today we're kind of seeing the
same thing you know it's a great first
game and here he tries to play it solid
maybe that doesn't suit him and now he's
on the well the receiving end of uh
some positional Masterpiece probably
yeah this is hands down the worst Bishop
I've ever seen uh that black light I'm
going to give you a hand clap for that
sorry I didn't mean
one of the worst pieces I've ever seen
David you are actually and people might
not realize this that not just like a
brilliant Grandmaster not just a top
level commentator not just a lovely chap
not just the gold medalists but the king
you are the the absolute Lord of puns
as well
do you think about them no I mean I was
just sitting here a second ago like
trying to come up with one
um yeah the promise people don't catch
them half the time so I feel a bit silly
I'm going to be quick for us
did you study English I did study
English literature at University yeah
not sure that helps with the puns so
much I was I was studying like Old
English where
that was a grind oh my gosh endless
reading
lots of long texts lots of long texts
yeah that's a surprise me you're into
the Shakespeare line mean that's the
hidden meaning in Beowulf but uh
I mean yeah I do enjoy a good pun yeah
that's a good pun and a good grind yes
and meanwhile this one is going to be a
grind but Hans he's moving his King away
is this the right side of the board do
you think guys he's I guess he's moving
even further with this King
I I maybe he's worried about a check
from the night at some point I mean it's
he's maybe he's just going to move it
back because he can't really do much
kind of need to improve the position I
mean he's he's just got to defend his
weaknesses and hope that Prague can't
can't break through here
um so I mean what is the next step in
improving the position it's really all
about how white improves the pieces and
what should white do now so well white
goes to your plan just improving the
Rooks doubling up the Rooks
um just get your pieces to the best
squares first and foremost yeah and
again probably playing very quickly just
kind of illustrating the point that when
you have a clear-cut plan when you know
it's just about simple Improvement of
the rook's Improvement of the night then
you can it kind of
the moves scream out to be played so you
can play very quickly now attacking a
pawn
it already looks like the white Knights
can start jumping in it looks uh just
terrible for black
and this B3 move coming a little bit
more tempting at some point you don't
need to play that though I mean again
don't rush for Pawn breaks if you can
achieve something of your pieces yeah
um but you call it you've got to you've
got to do The Next Step at some point
and um you reckon now maybe the Knight
can come in or yeah I mean there's two
tempting night jumps uh I'm not sure
which one I would start with probably I
would start with this one just because I
want to maximize this piece and this
piece before I start creating any action
um and maybe practice gonna think the
same you also mentioned this born break
Simon that's going to come at some point
uh just to open up this side of the
board open up lines uh where the black
king sits but first maybe put this piece
it's always nice to blockade an isolated
Pawn or a doubled pawn and
there we go he plays it I'm not sure
what black does
um I'm struggling to even find moves if
black just Waits next move we can start
jumping in with this Knight I think if
you can trade off this piece this is
Black's best minor piece it controls all
the dark squares if you can trade that
one off for either of the knights if you
can force him to capture then that's a
big game because now black has lost all
control of the dark squares this Rook is
on a permanent Outpost this other Knight
could start kind of dancing into the
squares that the uh kind of its previous
night was trying to use and
um yeah I mean this just looks glorious
okay Hans is waiting with his Bishop but
this uh yeah I'm not gonna make the same
pun but it is a very bad piece
um yeah the one thing you don't want to
do with white the one big mistake you
never want to capture it just leave your
opponent with a bad piece sometimes it's
better not to capture even if it's a
free piece just leave them with that
kind of locked in Bishop
oh
throwing a head for hands and uh I love
all the possibilities that you guys have
come up with and uh lo and behold the
Knight jumps in to this black half and
uh probably we're going to see the
bishop make a trade and uh whilst the
players are thinking and Hans is
desperately trying to find a way to
survive uh well a few more selfies from
uh from our viewers all over the world
um emiji Nikolai is a what sending us
greetings from Poland gadansk which I
know is a very beautiful city yeah looks
watching you on the phone at the
shipyard Marina how cool and Maritza is
also sending us greetings from Mauritius
with her unicorn mug and tea that's my
favorite favorite drink it's almost nine
o'clock there in Mauritius yeah so uh
it's so cool that you guys are watching
ever everywhere and Bon Reynold tibod is
working at home time whilst watching
Magnus against Levon here in Cebu
Philippines oh it's going to be late it
is going to be a bit late yeah and uh
yeah we have a move but yeah if you want
to enter our selfie competition then
please remember to send your selfie
using the hashtag chess Champs and very
importantly in landscape mode yeah
I was just thinking about tattoos though
tattoos oh yeah I was just thinking you
could have because Checkmate on your
finger or something okay I only said a
first time I came to Norway I met a guy
at the chess club he was a very scary
guy
very scary guy and he had one more beer
tattooed on his lip and he went to the
barn words one more beer yeah and he
just or one beer I think it was and he'd
just go
one beer yeah yeah he was really scary
guy I think he got into chess when he
was you know maybe locked up somewhere
yeah I don't know but Checkmate in your
finger you could just be like
like that you know when you're playing
or something
or how about in the lesson yeah if you
really go extreme you could be like uh
yeah I don't know I don't think I could
do the lip one no I mean you could pull
it off Simon I would support you if you
wanted it if I wanted to get a Checkmate
does that resign resign then you don't
have to say it no you don't have to say
you just go resign or on the middle
finger I love you didn't they you could
have resigned on your eyelids so you
just like it's a bit more it's a little
more messaging so as you go like that
quote from the Queen's Gambit you resign
now yeah yeah you resign now so yeah you
can just like close your eyes or a
picture of the the is it janitor or the
guy who says that yeah Mr scheibel yeah
many cool tattoo ideas and send them in
if you have some ideas as well we have a
move from my hand so it is a bit but
that bad Bishop is still locked up yeah
it's not a handsome Bishop
every time
but uh yeah the problem is for hunts
he's had to trade off his best Bishop
his better bishop and he's just going to
be left with that block of wood
um that light squared piece so
um again if we jump in there's a bit of
a decision here for Prague he has to
decide he's got two very tempting moves
you can capture with this uh this Pawn
or the other Pawn uh not 100 sure which
way I would capture to be honest they
both look great
um I'm slightly tempted to capture this
way just because black has the control
over the e-file anyway I don't need to
open up that line and then one plan for
white could be to maybe bring the Rook
up uh to this square and then start
picking off some of the weaknesses uh
that black has but
um yeah I mean there's an argument for
the other way as well if you capture the
other way later on you could maybe aim
to try and Conquer this Central File and
even if you swap off all the okay
um Prague has gone for this even if you
swap off all the Rooks I was going to
say even if all the Rooks get traded off
the board you're basically playing a
piece up in the end game because Black's
piece Black's Bishop is so bad and
what is this last move from us he's just
moved his Rook off the open file
handsome mistake yeah yeah maybe now you
can take over it just take over that
file and put the rook in the center of
the board I mean it just it just looks
it's you know to be honest the these
positions computers can put up some
resistant but for a human you get so
frustrated right and and you kind of
know you're going to lose anyway because
you're a piece down this bishop is not a
bishop of support and that's all you've
got to remember you can never do
anything with the bishop so uh well prag
take another approach there just taking
his time to double up on the open file I
guess I think his ideas actually dropped
his Knight back and into the center yeah
yeah and uh for example if black just
does nothing then this is just going to
be deadly not only is the Knight
attacking this Pawn but you can pretty
much just not move here's black
and uh yeah he'll decide what to do with
this bishop later it's just about
improving the White Knight and uh Heinz
finally making a move that I've been
dreaming about for the last 10 uh 10
moves because I mean that night was just
not doing a single thing at least put it
on the D6 Square as Dave is highlighted
and then maybe maybe you can get active
and just plonk it on C4
promise even if the Knight gets to an
active Square it could either get kicked
away later or it could just get traded
off by the white Bishop
we could see a scenario I mean for
example like this one uh where okay
after Bishop takes Knight it's just a
good night versus a bad Bishop scenario
and that's really instructive for
example I think black should take with
the other Pawn but if he takes this way
um yeah I mean
you can resign here I think this bishop
is just too bad and White's Knight is
glorious on an outpost oh gosh yeah but
I mean he's doing the right thing he's
putting his Knight on a on a semi-active
square at least and I mean if it does
jump to at least this Square it has some
control
um it covers some entry squares
I mean I'm trying to have some positives
here but it's
ugly I mean White is coming in at some
point
okay he chooses the other approach the
Knight is glorious here but he wants
another square and uh in this position
he's rerouting it around to attack this
backward Pawn maybe he can go the other
way David because you've got a couple
more tactical tricks there possibly as
well yeah actually this is a nice
Outpost as well could be winning a pawn
uh it you know quite well
or totally time black down this is this
forces the black Rook to come across and
now if you want to stop black jumping in
um actually you're right Simon we do see
this if you want to stop the night ever
jumping in you just push upon and
in this type of position black is almost
paralyzed
um what can black do I'm not sure how
white breaks through still maybe you can
try and use this file uh the open newly
open a file but uh either way there will
be plans
and we do have this position on the
board just a couple of years ago does
white go for this immediately that is
the question or does he try to take over
the open file
yeah that is a question I mean both very
very tempting I mean I would be
following your rules and pushing the
pawn in that pawn dominate the night
circuit uh that's that's the move I
would be tempted by and then you know
try to do everything actually Maxima
maximalist approach
so nice playing these positions with
white I mean we're talking about how
much hands has to suffer who had black
pieces but if you're ever in this
position to me you know I'm I'm known as
attacking player but I'd much rather
have had something like this because you
can just maneuver enjoy yourself improve
your pieces and it's actually a good way
to you know improve your sort of
positional play uh these kind of
positions um everyone at home should
look at games like this because it's all
about getting your pieces to the right
squares you know David's being explained
those ideas perfectly but just thinking
about how to improve in the long run not
tactically winning immediately but just
improving improving improving and
they're very thematic to getting better
at chess these these kind of uh smooth
victories I I mean you know not being
critical to hands it's just a horrible
opening he got I think you know it's
still one up so I mean he's got a he's
got a um think of another opening with
the black pieces that I think this just
doesn't suit him it's not yeah you're
right there Simon it's not as if he's
played badly hands he just chose a poor
opening and I think maybe just one
strategic decision and
this is the consequence that's unable to
move and okay he does push a pawn so
that uh that poor piece that black light
Square Bishop can maybe step away can
step back at some point
it's just whether it's in time White's
Rook can now occupy the a file start
trying to creep in over there
there we go
don't think black can challenge for that
file without losing a pawn
yeah I mean if you're really going to
let the white Rook start entering then
it's a bad sign white would love to
stack up two Rooks now on the a file and
that would just be disaster
yeah kind of Step by Step but it's it's
all working yeah what I like about uh
White's play is that there's been no
emotional attachment to any move it's
just been really just gradually
increasing the potential office pieces
you know the bishop was on B1 and now
it's found itself on the better Square
every single piece has just been
improved slightly and uh that's perfect
strategy yeah and also it's not a must
win situation for Prague but he is
behind in the match and this reminds me
of a famous uh famous world championship
match between Kasparov and karpov and
Kasparov needed to win the final game to
maintain his world championship title
and he needed to win with whites most
people just go all out attack but he
said no his strategy was to just kind of
slowly build slowly sit and the pressure
actually always gets to the person who's
in the lead they want to force things
they want to make a draw if they kind of
make negative decisions because of
external factors if you're just calm
even if you're behind in the match if
you come slowly do your thing you will
get a chance at some point and
yeah I just love what prague's doing
this is so mature I mean he's 17 years
old and he's just
kind of slowly grinding out some
strategic advantage
and okay Black's Bishop does retreat
defending some pawns probably a good
move yeah he's managed to move the
bishop yes it's uh it's it's semiolife
it's well he's trying to defend his
weaknesses over on the queen side now um
but the issue is uh you know one of the
right white Brooks come in I mean if you
know if black maybe exchange off all the
Rooks that's probably his best bet so if
somehow black can you know put his Rook
into the corner of the board and get all
the Rooks off
he still probably lose but he's he's got
more chances then
I think to hold that one problem is are
you in time can wait sir Rook on the
third rank now on the C file can it just
Retreat try to come across to the
um she can't put your rook in the corner
still right I mean well you lose a paw
in a clear pawn and he's done this is
the thing I mean uh he wants to step
across and this would be terminal if I
can conquer and as you mentioned there
Simon this move the desirable move
just met my met by an exchange and now
it's no surprise that all the tactics
work in White's favor after strategic
domination but he can just capture upon
this Rook is hanging if you take the
Knight now you lose your Rook due to a
pin on the C file
yeah something's dropping something's
got to give I guess here Hans just has
to make a decision does he want to kind
of just allow this and then suffer and
probably just lose on the spot or does
he want to at least give away a pawn and
get one set of Rooks off the board and
hope that
can somehow Go Active
I'm not sure he can go active here
that's the problem maybe you could just
move your Rook across defend this guy
when the Knight steps back
get the king out I mean you're pulling
down but at least your pieces aren't as
bad as they used to be
okay Hans doesn't give up the pawn
instead he moves his Rook away
and now I'm expecting I guess we're all
expecting uh Prague to take over the
open file
yeah yeah I'd say yeah I think so yeah
and Prague of course you know just
showing what a great player he is and
you know you reminded me David that he's
only 17 and I was reading an article
just now in New and Jazz magazine where
someone was playing against all these
kids and losing and you know so
traditional wisdom is that you know you
take them into an end game they don't
know what their player you know they
don't know how to play engage clearly
not true here and uh
and uh this uh the columnist's wife
actually came up on the solution is just
Why don't you just get lessons from
these 10 year olds who are good and he
came to a good attack tick so we've got
everything just pay them and learn their
secrets
on the Edge of Seventeen yeah
yeah and right now I mean I guess you
can improve this white knight you can
kind of Bring It Back and
I mean is there a defense to this the
White Knight stepping back
I don't see it the black king wants to
kind of run away to safety but if the
blacking starts running now at least you
can give a check and then you can give
another check and when the king moves at
the very end you have this Nighthawk
just feels like the tactics are starting
to work in White's favor as well
I think it's time you know what I do
here
resign that's what I do get it over with
I have to say you know the position
looks so dire that I would also I've
held on quite a long time to be fair I
mean yes they'll be resigning 20 moves
ago in this game so I'm doing better
today I think progress I'm fighting
harder in my mind
no but here here I mean it's just
complete dominance and as David pointed
out the patterns or and tactics all
favor white it's unsurprising I mean
just take a look at Black's pieces
they're clustered together awkwardly
placed ah that position just creaking
you know what I would do I might finish
in style uh try to self-mate myself so
Knight B7 and Bishop D7 again I'm trying
to you know just uh trying to try to get
a little little meeting there around my
king yeah I'd say but it's quite
artistic I love seeing it you know you
just allow Checkmate on the board why
not
yeah because you you don't you don't see
it at this level at all they never allow
oh that's good hello he's going for it
Bishop H3 Bishop D7 and come on Bishop
D7 allow the Checkmate or no he'll never
do that he will defend the pawn in a
different way and the game continues
I guess he's not completely done yet
right he's I mean he's Clinging On by
his fingernails but uh yeah yeah he's
defending everything for now I mean
maybe some crafty Rook B6 or something
just I don't know there's so many moves
here but I'm just thinking I I I'm now
trying to get black in I don't know it's
a Swank scenario but all just tactically
I mean there's so many ways probably to
do this yeah I would also be tempted
just to go for complete domination go
yeah well you know I've got the left
side why not take the center
I'm greedy like that you know what I
would do I would maneuver the white king
all the way over to the queen side and
just park it there you would be so
enjoyable
yeah he would be sat there wiggling with
a smug smile should I get this position
he's gone with my little mate they're
good good
I think like prag that is I'm really
happy about that because that's the kid
is good it's pretty much the best you
can get in chess these days thinking
like Prague he's he's he just impresses
me more and more prag I mean I I have to
be honest though I wasn't aware of many
of his games until I was able to
accommodate on the tour and I've had the
opportunity
um over some of these tours to see him
and this is this tour is so great for
watching these youngsters you know
people forget this um they're getting
more games in in the tour than they are
anywhere else and you can watch them
develop you can watch their Styles and
it's been really useful to me see the
development of Prague and tournament to
tournament he's just getting better and
better and uh mature and mature and it's
like wow you know after watching it
watching him in this tour I'm so
impressed by his play in so many
different positions not not just one
type of position but many you know when
he's trying to defend when he's trying
yeah he's really impresses me so totally
I mean like you say that Simon it's like
when you consider the very first
tournament he played in the air things
Masters
he was in the race to qualify he didn't
make it and you know he he actually
dropped points to Hans Neiman is a lot
more erratic and then the next
tournament he just got better and then
by the Oslo Esports cup
almost winning it yeah incredible stuff
yeah it really is
and I mean this is quite a funny
position isn't it I mean the night check
now probably just you know is one way to
win but it's a something more sadistic
over to Mr statistic here next to me
is that oh no maybe that would lose okay
let's not do that all right okay so I
found the only way to lose all right
let's not do that one yeah I mean it
it's all hands on deck right now Black's
pieces are just defending they're still
gay but yeah I mean this Rook is tied
down defending the night this trick is
tied down defending the night this
Bishop's tied down defending uh the F5
Pawn
I mean Black's only playing with his
King essentially you just need that
final kind of Catalyst that final
trigger to overwhelm Black's Army yeah I
just I don't really actually see it
right now the immediate breakthrough
like you said Simon you would love to
give the night check but suddenly can
the Knight go the other way then I was
thinking the lights could go the other
way and then the bishop could actually
switch back
yeah at some point you can switch back
and then sacrifice yeah I mean
everything's falling apart also this
night jump does threaten the killer uh
this killer night Fork uh for example if
black just Waits yeah this ends the game
instantly hit both Rooks at the same
time actually yeah I think you guys are
right um this is probably the most
simple way to do it
um I'm just wondering if
yeah can black movers night
he can't the problem is if you move your
knight now all of the Rooks are kind of
looking at each other a nice little kind
of diamond here but uh the problem is at
the end there is I mean all the tactics
work in White's favor are root capture
and at the end you capture the Knight
and uh a night jump night Fork you win
the game and he does play it every time
we say every time we stumble across a
strong move it probably seems to play it
he brings his Knight to this Square
we're gonna see a result any second I
think because uh after a trade this Rook
move is just going to overwhelm black
this Knight is kicked away and when the
night moves this check will just win the
house this is one track next move this
Pawn will fall
every Pawn here is just about to drop
look at all these weaknesses they are
all isolated all our light squares and
they are all going to drop
pity you have to take that Bishop to win
the game though maybe you know this is
the worst bishop ever all the pawns are
on the same color
yeah
that's just great technique from uh
Prague let's go back to the players he's
about to start picking off all the Pawns
there we go one of them drops still
Level material but a second Pawn will
drop now
hitting that yeah hitting that black
Bishop where does it even go
has to go the whole way oh it's out it's
out kind of still stuck still staring at
two points of its own pawns yeah the
reason we call it a bad Bishop is
because all of its pawns are on the same
color complex
maybe move the white king now towards
the center just lock it down I guess you
can capture a couple of different pawns
here for Prague oh he looks miserable
Hans Neiman winning game one today
against Prague but it's going to be a
loss here in game two so they will be
tied after two games with two rapid
games to go
in the match
he's still fighting though uh credit to
Hans
he'd never gave up he never resigned
even in the uh you know even in such a
really horrific position
um
yeah okay prank does take another Pawn
now
I think White's gonna end up with four
past pawns on one side of the board Hans
tries to defend in the center
um
I mean the white king can start coming
now
I just don't want to allow allow Black's
Knight to kind of jump out and start
capturing any uh Pawns in the center
Prague he's played perfectly so far he
hasn't taken any risks
I think he'll try to find a risk-free
way to convert this as well
five the computer says
despite only being one Pawn up that's uh
still shows the control he has in the
position yeah
yeah control and then
the thoughts I'm munching on the
material available
and he's gone for your plan David just
a lot of sense and there really isn't
too much
for hands to play I mean he can't really
defend any of his attacked pawns his
Knight does not want a great score
the bishop still a bad piece I mean he
has hands down a terrible positions
joining in there Simon oh God and okay
trying to find an open file at least the
black Rook but now any checks have been
stopped by white capturing the spawn so
now white has gone two pawns up
and Counting
okay he's going active this is what new
uh kind of tell players they should be
doing
is what everyone tries to do when they
know they're losing just go active it's
the best chance
okay the bishop is the best it's ever
been in this game uh since move one
maybe but it's still not necessarily a
great piece the White Knight can jump to
attack it
what or what do whites can maybe give a
track some options yeah I kind of
suspect that uh Prague might be super
clinical about this and just uh try to
advance his Pawns
yeah actually if that looks good it's a
lot of importance there clustered on the
right side of the board nothing to stop
them nothing in their way
in the other matches and other games
going on the bar is in the middle
between Magnus Carlsen and Levon aronian
Magnus one game one and it looks like
right now he will keep his lead if
thoronian is not able to come up with
something very clever in this game too
but look at that between alireza
ferrugia and Anish giri they drew the
first game and the part is over to
anishikiri's side he has lost both his
first matches in the tournament Anish
and he needs points
and it's looking good for him in this
game too against the young and great
alirez of Russia and also young
Christoph Duda against Liam Lair Liam he
won the first game and is he about to go
two points up in the match against Judah
that would be incredible for Le who's
also stuck on zero points after two
rounds in the tournament he could decide
this match in the next round with a draw
if he wins this game and Duda is shaking
his head he's not liking what's
happening in his match against Liam Lee
and in the game we are following Prague
could be about to tie the match against
Hans Neiman I guess it's getting quite
close and look at that the clocks as
well ticking but
price seems to be in control he's in
full control and uh he should be winning
any moment now
um I still love the fact that Neiman is
fighting or credit to him he's setting
some traps here and there practice had
to show some accuracy at least at the
end but now I mean I'm trying to
calculate you could have captured
Black's Rook you could have captured
Black's Bishop as Prague does and the
pawn probably you could capture the pawn
yeah it's all winning now and uh the
problem is the Black Knight is attacked
and he just lets it drop and there we go
white is a piece up and Neiman resigns
it's over for Hans Neiman young pregnant
he ties the match against the American
who won the first game but Prague cool
customers striking back as he always
does to tie the match and uh two rapid
games to go in their match
pregnant on that must be happy after
this one heading out to the lounge